the Haiti today is solving harder to get
a man he's crazy now I would love to
have morning I'm more descriptive title
for use an O there are trigonometric
rating is down for but harder except
what I'm going to show you is something
of a collection that is well the easiest
thing that binds them together is that
they're all a bit harder than what
you've done before so let me try to
illustrate what I mean for you we've
been solving simple three equations for
quite some time since last year really
good morning and I'll choose any double
want water sign X equal to fall that's
kind of your classic right I call this a
simple trig equation because well number
one it's got a trigonometric function it
over - it's got an equation number three
it's a very simple you can get because
this number T for example the real
answer to the hub is to give you a nice
convenient exact value back right if I
said just like I have all these
equations on the shape if I said to you
could you solve for 361 would your
solution fit for this one are you at a
point where you can just and you should
immediately 630 started that's exactly
imagine that
however we go from north to 360 you rest
good up and then it's going down you're
going to hit twice right after 30 you're
going to get 150 narrow your two
solutions okay so we should be starting
to get to the point where we're
comfortable enough with these where
especially here give it an exact value
now you can draw anything you don't need
to reach your calculator you could sort
of say okay with a bit of time I can
think about the answer is now we've
added three things on to that which is
what protocol to do but we're going look
at today
so suppose we here we have a look at
work done discreet pleasures like is
side on what were there doing some
grasses we modify those conclusions that
gave us different looking graphs we
spent a lot of time on graphing because
it's a key skill and it's quite hard to
development so it's always we modify
degrass whether I pretty say instead of
an X in there when put
in this or instead of Finance would have
to sign Eric's so what kinds of ways
doing but we are names for some of the
ways that we modified the tree Gretzky
member what someone would you find if I
change that X to a to X what would that
change we call that feature use a couple
dentro start with a nap
yeah frequency okay so that with your
modification we could change amplitude
if you move a tree to crazier than left
and right back and forth what we call
that one a phase location and there were
lots and lots of other ones there were
ships and what-have-you but the point
delete if you know what those look like
these one cetaceans of the tree graphs
well you can therefore solve equations
that have been modified functions in
filtering but a little more complicated
in that device we're going to photon or
recently we looked at the Pythagorean
identity we looked at complementary
identities and so on so these are
trigonometric identities these also
increase our repertoire of trigonometric
functions and equations that we could
work with right so I'm just going to
turn down plant Bogoria identity I think
the battery you've got the reciprocal
identities once you know what these
things are you can include them inside
your equations right and then you can
use them as you with this certain
equation to solve something else okay
there's one last sort of feature that we
looked at notice all of this which is
somewhat like moving symbols of radicals
as you but in terms of the visuals right
we looked at the unit circle as a
redefinition of the tree functions and
from there we also got grass so when you
extend the trigonometric functions
Justin triangles on to something about
the circumference of the unit circle you
can solve different kinds of equations
I'll show you them in a minute
so when you put all that together that's
what I'm sort of class
a hard a trigonometric equation and
you've got some other piece of paper
that you picked up when you walked in on
less you cannot pick it up when you
walked in so if you can look on with
someone next to you if that's you
I've written down for students just to
begin with so how it is a bit different
well the first one cos x equals 1 it's
pretty close to what you would call one
of these are simple treat equations but
I wonder if you do this the solution for
this task fit inside a triangle would do
it right because if you get adjacent and
hypotenuse one would be 1 over 1 right
well in a triangle whatever one adjacent
the high point is they can't be the same
length
the hypotenuse has to be the longest
side of the triangle right this guy's
not going to fit in triangle so what I'm
going to do and you can just do a small
messy one over here I'm going to draw a
new struggle to help me so I've got this
guy here now I will repeat to myself
climb X close X right is that the x
coordinate order y coordinate on the
unit circle it's the first yet the
horizontal coordinate right so you can
see where one is on TR that's over here
so therefore you can think of the angle
that goes with that
here it is what's the first angle that
meets that it's a zero right that'll be
opening one you can see the she I'm just
going to stand into Romania from north
to 360 so not only do you get dr but you
can get all the way around to a full
revolution and your maxima start which
is 300 degrees so there are two
solutions right from here I get x equals
e degrees or juices 360 you have to do
that so you can think you've got to
think about boyish triangles for these
kind of things we would call this by the
way if you want to give it a name we
will call it a boundary value problem
because when you're equal 1 or when you
equaling 0 or negative one point these
kind of things I have fitting triangles
anymore so you've got to go with these
testing or you control the ground
alternatively again if you want to shore
that moment see one hopefully you know
the graph of context one upside down
let's display and you can simply read
off when does that graph intersects with
one well that's the same spots I just
mentioned right zero and 360 periods of
here
okay so I the unit circle or the ground
will help you with that
right have a look at this one how will
you attack with it different piece of
knowledge that I'm going to use across
this more range of things I've developed
what I do to this equation to make it
easier so any Megan yes okay so this is
the reciprocal it's one over cause very
good good thing okay so you remember
when I told you that tree identity
solving like proving that this equals
this I said one of the main strategies
you should use when you take when stuff
is bring it back down to use more
columns of okay so we've done that
successfully I'm going to do one more
thing which is make connects the subject
so I'm going take the reciprocal of the
left which means I should take the
reciprocal of the right so far so good
okay now this is not an exact value so
I'm going to reach my calculator on the
front end so show you another line give
me
welcome to the nearest minute I would
say that's pretty standard for our level
of mathematics so how am I going to get
the first solution for COD x equals 1/4
what I'm gonna do yeah I'm going to go
out shift cause right and then I'm going
to put in a corner make sure you're in
degree mode by the way if you've I
borrowed the catheter from a friend it
might not be in degree mode so you can
get immersion shifts that [ __ ] already
picked up okay now what I called it has
the adjustable I still said to the
nearest minute so I'm going to keep my
eyes degrees minutes seconds funny
and it's going to
for me okay so I can think ed as equals
75 minutes 31 degrees
all right those five to ten degrees 31
minutes right around the right way
now that's the snow solution right I'm
expecting to and conveniently I already
have a graph code in order to help me
out how am I going to work out what the
second person yeah yeah very good so I
can use the symmetry of these contrast
LTI right to find that a clock where is
the quarter on here well that's what one
that would be about a half so that's
about quarter see you're great just up
and down so I'm going to draw that for
those a lot of drops like so just y
equals a quarter to detail my solutions
are here's the first one which
apparently obtained at 35 degrees by the
way just looking at my quick and dirty
brass does that match that what you'd
expect because look what this
interceptor certainly Decepticons rainy
so you expect only five to be just a bit
before so far so good and then by the
symmetry of the graph you can see all of
my other solution will be there which is
Michael suggested in not 0 plus 75 but
360 - so in my degree hunt and 31
minutes ok so why the answer is still in
your display you can go in 360 - info
and we'll take you back absolution for
let surrender there we go by the way
this is a perfect moment to recognize
that sense for me I'm going to write out
the whole calculated display
okay this is what my pepper displaces
okay so you've got the greatest ten
minutes then seconds but the bit we've
mishmash of unified considers guard out
here
it's a decibel right because after
seconds we don't thought the story or
force or anything like that so that's
just a decibel but between these two
guys right how many mean second driver
in a minute there are 60 seconds in it
just like it was your client okay
so therefore this 39 actually rounds up
because it's over which is over halfway
okay as a common thing to forget people
alike are you know I want to be 50 or
above to round up so this is seconds and
minutes this is in imperial bit
I've got a decimal thing except for the
invit so therefore can I round this
properly I'm going to say or to 84
degrees and 20 minutes and of course you
can confirm that for yourself because
look city dipping - yup they're going to
line up if I'd rounded that down to 28
these wouldn't add up to 60 anymore so
it wouldn't be the 1400 suitors